Now with all these bindings you hopefully got an overview of how you can work with
Svelte
and its bindings to conveniently get access to foreign values and using two-way binding here
really is extremely helpful and you'll often use it when working with forms.
There is another way of getting access to any element on the page though, so besides
using
two-way binding and also not limited to inputs.
let me first demonstrate it with the help of an input though let's say here we
have an input and
we have a button and i only need to value once i clicked that button so
here in on click i'll
trigger save data which is a function i have yet to add so let's do that
quickly here we have
save data and i'm not accepting any event object in here because that would be my
click event and I'm not interested in that but I do want to get the text
that was entered into
this input. Of course we could set up two-way binding with bind value and then
storing that
data which is in that input in some variable. But if I only need this in
a read-only way and I never
set the value anywhere else I could do it and it would not be wrong and
in most cases you will
probably do it with two-way binding but you can actually also simply read the value
from the input.
So of course, what we could do here is we could console.log, document, query, selector,
and then maybe give this some ID, username.
So hashtag username selects by ID.
Let's now give this here the ID, username, so that this is selected.
And now we get access to this element.
And since it's input element, this will have a value property.
And if we do that and we save that all,
and I enter super or whatever you want here,
and I click save, you see that being printed.
This is not the svelte-ish way of doing it though.
This is vanilla JavaScript code, which you can use,
but there's a more elegant solution.
And you might remember that I used a similar approach
earlier in the course where I also used query selector
because I had no better tool for the job.
Now, actually, there is a better tool.
You can use binding, but a special form of binding.
So instead of relying on selecting this by ID,
you can instead add bind,
but now you don't bind to value
because I don't want two-way binding,
but to this,
which is simply a special syntax understood by Svelte.
This thing here is not a normal attribute
you could add to an input.
This is simply understood by the Svelte compiler.
And by binding to this,
you can store a reference to that element here,
a pointer to that element in a variable of your choice.
So now we can add a new variable,
username input, for example.
And this is the variable which I'll use down there,
username input.
So now a pointer at this HTML element
or at this DOM element, to be precise,
is stored in username input.
And therefore here in save data,
I can now console.log username input.value
because this points at this HTML element.
And hence now if I enter super here and I click save,
you see that still works,
but of course that's way shorter
than manually selecting this with query selector.
And we also don't have to add the ID.
We can remove that
because now this reference and connection
is set up behind the scenes by Svelte.
Now this is not two-way binding.
This is really just a pointer at the full element.
We're not restricted to reading its value.
We can do whatever we want.
We can manipulate it, though I would not recommend that.
You shouldn't change it programmatically.
You should always change your DOM through Svelte
by the instructions you place down there.
But you can read any data you want.
You can check out the CSS classes on the element.
You can do whatever you want because if we log it,
you'll see it's just a full element.
So if a console log this here, and I press save again,
it's the full input.
way if you want to inspect it here you can use console dir and now you
get a inspectable javascript
object so this is really the full dom element and this does not just work with
html input elements
it works with any html element and your own components as well so we can also
use a div
instead and bind this to some div which of course is a variable i have yet
to add so here is
some div and now for simplicity when we click save data i can now also console
there there
some div so it's the same button as before but now i'm binding this here this
div to the sum div
variable and therefore i can now interact with the div and inspect it and do whatever
i want
again changing something there is not recommended you should always do that with the help of
swells
normal syntax, but reading values from it can be really useful.